nous retrouvons daniel lessard
aujourd'hui encore bonsoir daniel ottawa
tâche a grandi nous est à toronto et un
autre invité michel david à montréal
bonsoir une chaîne en soi alors on va
parler de la campagne au québec mais je
veux vous faire entendre deux extraits
encore le niqab et on vient tout de
suite après on a tout à gagner à voter
pour des femmes et des hommes qui
tiennent les conservateurs choisissent
la politique de la peur hein et le bloc
québécois existe à cause de la politique
de division 1 alors ça devrait pas être
surprenant qu'on est en train de voir un
tel mans 2-2 d'énergie dépensée sur ces
discussions polarisantes discussions
polarisantes je trouve qu'il faisait
référence au niqab l'extrême monsieur
duceppe ça c'est le slogan ce n'est pas
l'extrait sur l'unique hamelin l'a
entendu un peu plus tôt c'est à peu près
comme hier d'ailleurs on continue à dire
que les autres partis doivent clarifier
leurs propos à michel david
est ce que est ce que cette histoire du
niqab réussi à donner un peu d'air à la
campagne du bloc qui en cherchent est
beaucoup un peu d'air temporairement
sans doute parce que c'est un sujet qui
est que le bloc est capable de avec
lequel il est capable d'attirer
l'attention à des problèmes du bloc
depuis le début c'est que tout ce qui
dit s'attendre à peu près d'enlever de
là il ya un sujet qui je pense va
accrocher mais temporairement si vous me
demandez si en bout de ligne ça va avoir
un effet déterminant je ne passe pas
souvenez-vous de la charte dans tout le
monde trouvait ça bien épouvantable et
libéraux leur position qui voulait
interdire aucun signe s'est enfargé dans
le tchador et en bout de ligne ça leur
produit du tout alors je pense pas que
le 19 octobre ça va être marquant dans
l'urne d'achat et daniel on a parlé hier
et on le voit sas a suivi les caravanes
des chefs aujourd'hui monsieur mulcair
entre autres à qui on a posé huit fois
la question monsieur un peu également
seriez vous prêt même aller jusqu'au
nonobstant là on essaie de sortir tout
le jus de cette histoire leurs derniers
arguments ou tâche à l'hésitation
on essaie de le sortir parce qu'on est à
la veille du débat et après c'est un
autre débat aussi en français on sait
que c'est très important cette question
parce que c'est vraiment la seule
possibilité présentement que le bloc
peut percer ou changer ces fortunes un
peu comme michel a dit je sais pas si ça
va durer mais ça durerait au moins
pendant la période qu'on en parle à ces
débats là certainement hills a fait
revivre toute la question de l'identité
québécoise qui est très épineuse pour
monsieur 1015 justement parce que à
l'extérieur du québec
on veut pas qu'ils soient trop
nationaliste et au québec est courtois 7
ce vote là alors c'est très compliqué
pour lui et pour monsieur harper une
baisse des formules de lampes et des
filets des dents certains cours d'eau et
ça peut aussi malheureusement pour lui
ai dit le bloc daniel aujourd'hui
monsieur me quinquis avait patienté un
peu après deux trois questions là-dessus
pile à dire la journaliste c'est comme
si vous me demandiez d'enlever la
liberté de presse donc moi un droit
c'est un droit sauf que il si jamais
clair sur l'unique à mes réponses sur
les droits en tout cas je mes frères et
c'est jamais très populaire au québec il
ya sûrement plusieurs personnes qui
s'étaient promis de voter pour le
nouveau parti démocratique et qu'il a
repensé peut-être leur position est ce
que dans l'isoloir de 19 octobre la
question qui vont se poser est ce que je
suis pour ou contre le niqab pas
certains moi non plus mais si le bloc
doit décoller c'est cette semaine que ça
doit se passer
le niqab est un bon tremplin pour le
bloc est ce que ça peut le mener jusqu'à
une bonne performance 19 octobre
je ne sais pas peut-être peut-être pas
et gilles duceppe doit aussi faire la
preuve jeudi que bon sur le niqab c'est
un instrument important mais faire la
preuve que le bloc n'est pas sûr partie
dépassées n'est pas un parti fini qui
peut encore être pertinent que j'ai dit
c'est avec une poignée de députés disons
une douzaine là pour avoir un statut
officiel peut bien représenter les
intérêts des québécois
si ça ne décolle pas cette semaine elle
ça va être très difficile du cil à faire
d'accor un mot là-dessus d'achat et
michel sait que c'est symptomatique
michel vous l'avez dit mais que le niqab
soit le seul sujet où le bloc a réussi à
percer la grille des médias ça en dit
beaucoup aussi touchant pas ça dit
beaucoup écouté c'est parce que je pense
que les grands enjeux économiques c'est
pas vraiment la force du bloc on a vu
que l'indépendant qui sont représentés
beaucoup de québécois dans les gagnants
quatre années ont eux fait vraiment
valoir je pense beaucoup de valeur
économique québécoise dit québécoise
peut-être un peu plus de gauche et le
bloc québécois il est je pense plus sur
la question nationale la question
d'identité parce que c'est l'heure c'est
vraiment le rein leurs points forts mais
mes yeux il ya eu deux des gros
événements qui ont complètement
monopolisé l'espace médiatique ça a
commencé avec le défi guèye est ensuite
la récession l'immigrant maintenant le
niqab alors est certain que des
questions comme celle là alors que le
bloc relativement peu de haut parleurs
il ya participé à aucun des débats
jusqu'à présent il était très difficile
de percer cette espèce de monopole
avec avec des questions québécoise
demain il va avoir l'occasion je pense
pour la première fois de parler de
choses comme les l'empiètement des
juridictions par le gouvernement fédéral
la question linguistique est ce que par
exemple monsieur molière jusqu'à quel
point il est prêt à amender la loi pour
permettre aux entreprises fédérales
d'être soumise à 300 il ya toutes sortes
de sujets comme cela qu'ils font qui ont
pratiquement pas eu des coups même si le
bloc a cédé faire le vide ou cadeau même
monsieur monsieur je suis déjà rendu là
on va avoir l'occasion la deûle y met
sur la table très bien tu n'as tu as tu
patrice genin maria mourani ce matin
avec alain gravel ya plusieurs candidats
néo démocrates au québec qui sont
vraiment pas à l'aise avec la position
de mulcair sur la sur le niqab est ce
que ça pourrait s que ça pourrait
éclater institué lequel on pourrait
sortir du rang probablement pas mais on
sent un malaise aussi de ce côté-là rien
mieux au mont rainier qui dans un
reportage qu'on a diffusé hier pour le
pipeline le change de sujet complètement
mais pour le pipeline pour illustrer un
peu quand même cette ambiguïté qui
demeure du côté du chef du npd qui a dit
nous c'est non à condition qu' il ya
assez de garanties environnementales
elle n'a pas dit à l'électeur à qu'elle
parlait dans le reportage c'est oui à
condition donc on joue un peu sur les
sur les deux tableaux quoi oui ça c'est
la position de la fête du gouvernement
du québec actuellement monsieur
couillard en fait tout le monde sait que
il souhaiterait que ce pipeline là se
réalise mais il comprend que ça prend un
peu de 2 comment dire de nuances
voilà alors y multiplie des conditions
mais en bout de ligne c'est oui mais
c'est oui mais mais j'ai l'impression
que le oui plus gros clamé voilà un
emploi changement de sujet une seconde
qui promet un peu plus d'un million
d'emplois pour les quatre prochaines
années nicole 90% sont des jobs à temps
plein plus de 80 % sont dans le secteur
privé
ils sont dans des industries avec avec
des
des salaires élevés il n'y a pas de
raison pour laquelle on ne peut
atteindre un tel objectif pendant les
cinq années à venir
tasha 1.3 million à 4 est à peu près ce
que l'économie sans grands coups de
fouets donnons mais environ une moitié
de sault seraient donnés par l'économie
sans grands efforts du gouvernement les
conservateurs promettent de couper les
cotisations pour l'assurance emploi ils
vont faire renaître le programme de
subventions pour les rénovations à
domicile alors ils pensent que ces
choses là et si que le fai qui
n'augmenterait pas les impôts sur les
entreprises ça permettrait une
continuation une augmentation des
emplois en sus aux dépens effectivement
si l'économie continue à croître à une
vitesse n'est pas normal et une vitesse
qui est prédit les prédictions sont
maintenant à la baisse alors est-ce que
ça met en péril cela écoute sur cinq ans
ils ont déjà créé sur quatre affaires
dont environ un million 3000 emplois
300000 emplois alors c'est faisable et
c'est intéressant je serai juste un
autre mot là dessus parce qu'on enterre
you les conservateurs ont fait une
semblable commerce un million d'emplois
sur huit ans ça les a pas servis
énormément pendant la dernière élection
provinciale ici reste à voir si ça va
faire au national des 166 fait des
couilles en quoi 258 commun 250 mais
c'est toujours des promesses qui sont
retrait attire une clientèle qui le
regrette un peu de ces chiffres-là bien
mais dans le cas de stephen harper il ya
deux choses qu'il ne dit pas c'est sa
promesse repose sur deux secteurs dont
il ne parle pas aujourd'hui qui sont
importants un l'énergie il fait
probablement le pari que des prix du
baril de pétrole reviendront à des
niveaux intéressants et deuxièmement que
des pipelines sont reconstruits soit
dans l'inconnu britannique soit vers le
texas où soit vers le québec du nouveau
brunswick tout à l'heure je l'avais
clinton a dit non carrément acquis stone
elle sera t-elle élu président des états
unis je ne sais pas été bien placé mais
ça regarde mal de ce côté là l'autre
truc dont on ne parle pas monsieur
harper c'est que une bonne partie de sa
création d'emplois repose sur ses
traités de libre échange il a signé en a
au moins une vingtaine depuis qu'il est
au pouvoir mais deux gros contrats avec
l'union européenne et ce partenariat
trans pacifique dont on parle en ce
moment à long terme c'est prometteur
ça peut permettre de créer beaucoup
d'emplois
le prix du baril du pétrole remontent à
des niveaux acceptables mais sur un peu
vert jenny il ya des mais oui il ya des
mecs michel autres sur le terrain
politique il veut reprendre le chapeau
de monsieur économie monsieur je
contrôle la situation de l'emploi la
même si il ya un certain laisser faire
et je me cache pas derrière
oui tout à fait au cours des dernières
semaines je pense que c'est monsieur
trudeau qui a pris davantage sur ce
terrain là parce que lui avance des
solutions que d'aucuns pourront trouver
drastique qu'elle multiplie les déficits
investir beaucoup plus massivement des
infrastructures mais enfin ce sont des
moyens qui sont de nature à créer de
l'emploi maintenant monsieur harper a
été rejeté par winnipeg quand il a fait
cette annonce là aujourd'hui
mais si je comprends bien c'était pas un
engagement très ferme
c'est un objectif c'est ouais un peu
comme monsieur l'état a voulu le module
et au québec
et quand il ya dix ou finalement c'était
pas de promesses et ajuste un objectif
ça ressemble beaucoup plus à ça et je
voyais les dernières projections de
l'eau cds sur la croissance canadienne
ils ont abaissé sa un point pour ça si
ça se maintient dans c dans ces eaux là
il n'y arrivera pas ça mais il doit
parler d'emploi c'est un des points sont
comme on nous l'a dit monsieur trudeau a
dit qu'ils créent des infos alors
messieurs un peu doit répondre là dessus
et je pense pour l'électorat
c'est une question très important
particulièrement dans l'ouest où il ya
une pénurie d'emploi à cause de baisses
de prix pétrole et où les sièges des
conservateurs dans certaines même
akhalgori peut-être sont menacées en
particulier par des candidats libéraux
voilà messieurs dames c'est tout le
temps passe tellement vite c'est tout
merci on se retrouve pour certains
d'entre vous demain michel on va se
retrouver
épisodiquement aussi ça nous fait
toujours plaisir de vous accueillir
merci à la prochaine au revoir